a new integration between invisi and
turbonomic exciting updates from IBM
power and the IBM Cloud internet
services standard Next plan all on this
episode of IBM Tech now what's up y'all
my name is Ian and I am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements about IBM technology
I want to start this week with a new
software integration between IBM and
busy and IBM turbonomic together the
integrated solution provides cios with
near real-time visibility of data center
energy demand and Emissions impact at an
application Level
this enables timely optimization of data
center resources and workload placement
with their deep understanding of the
role of data and their expertise in
technology cios are well positioned to
make a meaningful impact on their
organization's sustainability agenda
in the invisi turbonomic integration can
enable cios to take the following three
actions to help reduce energy
consumption and transform sustainability
ambition into action
first is to lead with action by
automating optimization in the data
center to safely improve Energy
Efficiency
second is to set the standard by
ensuring the business unit impact on
sustainability performance is visible at
the corporate level
and third is to establish a company-wide
data architecture to help with
sustainability performance tracking at
the Enterprise level and support
corporate ESG reporting
to learn more about the specifics of how
the invisian turbonomic integration can
help with these initiatives check out
the link in the description of this
video
next up as the global economic Market
continues to fluctuate amidst Rising
interest rates and inflation IBM powers
and unveiling several updates designed
to help clients move forward with their
digital transformations in these
turbulent times
some of these updates are designed to
optimize performance and Energy
Efficiency with IBM's first known pcie
direct attached 24-bay nvme storage
drawer in the industry
we're also helping simplify the
management and data protection of IBM I
environments the latest technology
refreshes for IBM I are shipping in May
and we're now delivering tape backup
solutions for IBM I environments running
on power 10.
finally we're minimizing the total cost
of ownership for sap Hana with new
configurations to lower the cost of
moving to sap Hana on a compute platform
with best-in-class reliability
for the full details on all these IBM
power updates hit the link below
finally as we Mark the fifth year of our
partnership with cloudflare IBM is
announcing the general availability of
the new IBM Cloud internet services
standard Next plan
the standard next release provides the
same core features that are part of the
standard plan with some great new
features
the new plan introduces the ability to
add an additional domain removes the
protected traffic ceiling of five
terabytes removes the DNS queries in
HTTP request ceiling of 10 million and
add support for a maximum of three
origin servers for Global load balancing
for the full rundown of the new IBM
Cloud internet services standard Next
plan hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now